dos años de investigación y 12 días de
redadas conjuntas y simultáneas en
varios países europeos y en emiratos
árabes Unidos han terminado con la
detención de 49 personas vinculadas a un
megacartel de droga que movía un tercio
del mercado de la cocaína en Europa esta
trama que podría perfectamente ser el
guión de una película de ficción forma
parte de una operación policial
internacional apodada luz del desierto
coordinada por europol la policía
europea entre los 49 detenidos están los
seis líderes de este megacartel que
dirigían el tráfico desde Dubai
conocidos Como los señores de la droga
en la operación en la que participaron
España Países Bajos Francia Bélgica y
emiratos árabes Unidos se incautaron
además 33 toneladas de cocaína y se
desmanteló la infraestructura logística
en varios puertos de Europa por donde
entraban las drogas desde latinoamérica
en España donde el pasado 8 de noviembre
fueron detenidas 13 personas la
operación inició en marzo de 2020 con la
inca de un contenedor con casi 700 kilos
de cocaína en Valencia al este del país
Pese a que en ese entonces no hubo
detenciones se identificó a Panamá como
el país en el que se introdujo la droga
en ese contenedor según datos de la ONU
la mitad de los 20 países que más
consumen cocaína del mundo son europeos
y según el observatorio europeo de
drogas y toxicomanías España es el país
europeo con más prevalencia de consumo
de esta droga con el 11,2% de la
población entre los 15 y los 64 años
afirmando que consume cocaína